hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich habe meine community also
die luke crew in einer instagram story
gefragt ob sie mir nicht einige male
zusenden können und da wurden mir einige
zugeschickt die wirklich sehr
interessant waren sage ich mal wie
beispielsweise der hier was ist braun
knusprig und schwimmt unter wasser
person schreibt einfach nur brot und die
antworten auf des rätsels lösung ist ein
brot
ja
ich würde eigentlich jetzt schon
abschalt beim nächsten rot sein fell
schreibt ein mädchen ihrem freund um
22.14 ey was machst du einige minuten
später schickte er ein fragezeichen in
genau der gleichen minute schreibt sie
noch hallo und zwei minuten später
schreibt die junge geht es noch mal wo
bist du
alter ich war gerade in einem tunnel
beruhig dich h ok hoffe ich für dich
toxisch beziehung komplett durchgespielt
h ich hab dich heute in der stadt
gesehen was wo warte habe auch ein foto
gemacht
ich scheiß vor deiner haustür du penner
[Musik]
humor was lebt in der savanne und ist
immer sauber kein plan eine hygiene
rom zu hause nein dann müssen wir wohl
rummachen
haben tue ich mir das immer ein fenster
auf den moment wenn du zwei dinge in der
hand hast und dann das falsche in den
mülleimer wirst ja
es ist genauso wie wenn man sich
irgendwie was vornimmt um irgendwie was
in der küche oder im badezimmer zu
machen und dann ist man im raum
angekommen fragt sie ja nur noch so hey
warum bin ich jetzt noch mal hier mein
nachbar hat heute um 83 bei mir
geklingelt echt oha wieso nicht so
schlimm ich war noch wach da ich
trompete geübt habe
[Musik]
neulich habe ich sie gefragt warum ich
single bin weiter sie hat die
frontkamera geöffnet
morgen machen wie bitte sorry
autokorrektur h ich dachte auch schon
ich meinte heute
warum habe ich bin nicht youtube pause
nicht einfach noch bis nächstes jahr
durchgezogen er kam zu mir eingefallen
machen wer sagt gefallen machen es heißt
gefallen tun ja klar was ist kannst du
meinen facebook status bitte oft chillen
mit jesus stellen wenn ich tot bin froh
was mich viel mehr verwundert ist dass
du noch facebook hast
habt ihr das eigentlich mitbekommen dass
facebook einfach demnächst umbenannt
wird auf metall oder
irgendwie der konzern wird in dimitar
mit hoch sprachenlernen gott ich will
morgen nicht in die schule mama ist
lehrerin ja aber wir schreiben morgen
eine arbeit in der ah ja und die sind
alles so dumm zum mit welchem ziel
ich war aber trotzdem
gab es für euch auch immer so dieses
standard klischees bei jeder klasse bei
uns war die absolute streber klasse b
waren die absoluten gangster die ihnen
nichts auf die kette kriegt haben sie
das waren wir wir waren eigentlich ganz
normal aber eher zur b angelehnt als
zwar und idee
[Musik]
hatte irgendwie niemand mit denen hatte
irgendwie niemand etwas zu tun
das ist genauso ein mysterium wie die
verschiedenen farben für verschiedene
fächer bei mir hundertprozentig ist es
so eingebürgert rot heißt deutsch
mathe und gelb heißt englisch
streitet euch jetzt gerne in den
kommentaren dass ich das falsch gemacht
oder papa habe einen neuen freund gut
dann kann ich ja mein gewehr testen
lassen
auch bei meiner schwester so viele sind
dann so ja wenn die kleine schwester ein
freund hat dann ist man erst mal so
warum hat ihnen freuen soll jedoch
machen alter start sollen wir uns ein
schönes wochenende machen ja
ok damit ist montag
[Musik]
also lustig war es eigentlich und corp
habe ich auch schon mal bekommen kannst
du lesen ja in meiner hose steht was
wird
schwer verarscht diese leute die sowas
schreiben oh mein gott was ist seit wann
sind die zusammen der ja seine
augenbrauen
es wirklich einfach noch leid willst du
einen witz herrn ja unsere beziehung
ich hätte das auch teilweise gar nicht
mehr
also wirklich an alle die meine ins heim
story lage sehen wir dass zugeschickt
haben bittet de abonniert mich auf
instagram alter wie so liebst du
jemanden wenn du weißt dass sie eh nie
zusammen kommen werde dieser art ist
obwohl du weißt dass du sterben wirst
stimmt es genauso wie die diese diese
dumme empfehlung die man manchmal so
bekommen zu ja man ist irgendwie traurig
und dann weint man und dann sagt einem
kumpel in dieser haye wäre doch einfach
glücklich
ihr sagst du auch jemanden der asthma
hat mir doch einfach charts
wer kürze das skz abschnitt
anders denkst du gerade an nix
besonderes schade ich dachte du denkst
an mich habe ich doch
was holen korb oder
auch so einen korb
warum sagt man eigentlich dass ein korb
um korb kriegen
ich sah eigentlich voll was geiles wenn
ihr jemanden corp schenkt mama bitte
erschreckt nicht ich musste was sagen
ich bin im krankenhaus der witz ist die
letzten acht jahre die dem krankenhaus
arbeitest nicht lustiger geworden
ich fand irgendwie bisher keinen
einzigen mordfälle heute lustig neun
andere youtuber würden jetzt
wahrscheinlich so tun als wären es die
krassesten whatsapp fehlt und blabla
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich ich ganz vorne
ganz verstehen in dem video ihren daumen
runter gibt
wenn nicht könnt ihr natürlich um hoch
da lassen um einen kanal abonnieren doch
die glocke klicken dann verpasst ihr
euch das neue minecraft video morgen
das getan hat ich hatte heute
boxtraining habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch
meiner ins restaurant gesehen als sonst
tut alles weh allerdings würde ich sagen
kommen wir jetzt auch schon zum letzten
wort fällt fürs heutige video uns was
ist dieser hier geht ein panda über die
straße
gezeigten
bambus
nach fähigen bambus und
wegen da kommt ein bus
wer hat dir ins hirn geschissen deckert
das frage ich mich auch
was ich mich auch fragt meine lieben
freunde ist warum ihr noch kein abonnent
von einem kanal seid wenn ihr schon seid
dann vergessen ist einfach aber ich muss
ja alle ansprechen hier deswegen
macht es einfach nicht
ich kann euch auch wirklich einen grund
nennen warum man das tun sollte
aber ihr könnt gerne wenn jetzt trotzdem
wollte jetzt hier einfach auf den smiley
klicken dann könnt ihr mich nämlich
abonnieren und hier ist ein anderes
video verlinkt wo ich damals schon mal
auf whatsapp feld reagiert habe war auch
nicht viel witziger
sogar tendenziell noch beschissener er
[Musik]